slide
sporting itself Oh
hello there thanks for stopping by
before this one starts I wanted to let
you know that I'm thinking about
starting a gameplay channel a place to
upload random shenanigans with my
friends and full game playthroughs -
it's only an idea at present but if that
sounds good to you I'd appreciate a sub
over there anyway thanks for your time
let's play some modern warfare we need
some epic gamer moments so I'm gonna go
up the middle that's the other minor
crash there and now I've changed my mind
okey dokey I will be your cannon fodder
I didn't see him peek left I'm gonna
push up through this wooden okay
together behind he's behind the walls to
the right soon as you come out
sacrificial lamb
love a bit of free fire there but a
sexual pre-fire molesty two days coming
back to haunt me
I got a sniper just got us night again
no peek from my guy got mine
open for my guys doing some kind of
funny business again him it's him don't
worry about it honestly look we've lost
four times I will simply cut down ours
only at one pistol bullets worth of
health left nobody will know about how
bad you just played
[Music]
I honestly thought I'd got that with
that crazy ass move in fact slightly can
I title the video for you right now and
go on to call of duty modern warfare
pros pros and all-caps go on unreal
unreal in all caps killing all enemies
all the time flag to win where I can see
my words in that mm riot four hits on
this victory Street brackets longest
victory streak ever brackets there's
even more brackets in that title match
is about to begin
my partner is on the toilets or on the
phone phone is down I'm here committed
throws on what we thought willing is
this gun full auto fire on this one oh
my god I can't hit my shoes I am
terrible the nutcase I should just give
you my perspective because all I did was
come round a corner and see a guy take a
beagle bullet to the dough so they
played offensive I'm gonna get an A one
shot at this oh my god he does not miss
his shots
left far left
if you really know Dean Thomas takes me
try did he just with his bullet
completely I think so Alton out of that
or he underestimated how its health
ahead and will you order to look cool so
he slid it and died I'm gonna try it now
slide you don't need me I can do my
slides whenever I like slide to the left
[Music]
TJ's it's almost like you need to
remember I'm over ones above me nice
once a day in my honor
in there look at where he was
yeah I tried to throw away a Molotov up
there and I ended up suffering it the
wall in front of me again so I'm used to
Molotov tonight and have hit myself with
both of them
smokey I like it yeah you get a Molotov
killed by the end of the night I'm
feeling dude nice middle one he was on
me he's on me he's going into the middle
of a mall the things the crates
[Music]
lucky boy yeah he's very lucky to get
killed like that Jamie Jamie Jamie Jamie
Jamie Jamie Jamie Jamie dance before we
go what are we doing to do any like
whatever we like I love it was my
favorite game plan nothing I got em
don't worry about it Jamie I'm gonna say
I'm gonna snipe with a pistol I love a
shot what's this
I want to use this let me just try this
normally okay oh man that was close I'm
gonna fistfight my guy
right
yeah my beats running it though oh my
god that's what we see he tried to whack
you at the end there dude that was so
good come on one more to win we can go
to bed I've hit my I've killed my god
Russia man you get your you get your
fists out let me go first and then your
first I'll be the distraction
the truck is attention in front of me up
in the air they're the ones back left Oh
oh I'm dead he's come back to us born on
them and he's dead oh damn it we didn't
punch him always to be really close do
you one look I could have absolutely
fisted that art that no don't finish
that one Adam flippin hell man look at
those kills and dance that was the most
when I had though tried to get fist
kills that was a lot of fun right Jamie
thank you very much for your time do you
want to say anything about yourself to
impress people I'm really cool and I'm
even cool once you get to know me Jamie
runs a podcast called super show pod is
that correct
yeah sure that works look it up on on
iTunes and the youtubes and all the
other things and yeah it's been a
pleasure playing with these dude I shall
see you again thank you for having me
indeed
[Music]